vamos a actualizar las noticias de la
economía con Daniela Blandón Daniela
saludo nuevamente para usted Hola Ángela
Buenos días y comenzando más bien con
una noticia de tono grave el regulador
de valores de Estados Unidos demandó a
la segunda firma de criptomonedas en
menos de un día lo acaba de hacer Ángela
la comisión de bolsa y valores que es la
sec demandó a la plataforma de
criptomonedas coinbase una de las cinco
más grandes del mundo por operar como
una bolsa de valores y un corredor de
bolsa sin estar registrada a esto lo
hace apenas Un día
después de haber hecho lo propio con la
mayor plataforma de intercambio de
criptomonedas del mundo se trata de
binance y su fundador champen quienes
están acusados de lo mismo Pero además
de malversar fondos de inversiones
mezclarlos y desviarlos a cuentas bajo
el control de su fundador también
falsear las cifras del negocio y mentir
sobre los mecanismos de seguridad
internos
vamos a hablar sobre la importancia de
vainas que fue digamos el primero en
caer Dentro de este castillo de nikes
claro y de vainas y de Coin veis porque
estas demandas traen a la memoria del
caso de ftx de hecho algunas de las
acusaciones de las que se enfrentan son
las mismas que también están afrontando
esta empresa y su fundador la
importancia de estas empresas se radica
en su participación de Mercado a finales
del año pasado vainas había acaparado
más del 60% del volumen transado en
criptodivisas en el mundo y coinbase
alrededor del 7% Daniela usted
invertiría en criptomonedas yo no lo
haría personalmente me parece un negocio
muy riesgoso y tampoco está regulado por
las autoridades y aquí estamos viendo
algunos de los efectos de eso Tiene
mucha tiene muy buena muy buena
rentabilidad rentabilidad pero al mismo
tiempo es muy riesgoso Bueno vamos a
hablar entonces de los indicadores si le
parece pues hablando precisamente de las
en estas empresas coinbase que cotizan
la bolsa de Nueva York estaba cayendo
casi un 20% antes de la apertura en Wall
Street Mientras que el precio del
bitcoin cae más del 1% tras verter un 5%
el lunes ahora se cotiza en poco más de
25 mil dólares su nivel en dos meses un
nivel más bajo los principales índices
de Wall Street entre tanto abrieron
ligeramente a la baja a medida que los
inversores están evaluando las
posibilidades de que la reserva Federal
mantenga sus tasas de interés en la
reunión de la próxima semana y en el
Asia Pacífico Un sorpresivo aumento de
las tasas de interés en Australia les
recordó a los inversionistas que la
lucha contra la alta inflación todavía
continúa y que los costos de los
préstamos globales no han llegado a su
punto máximo vamos a cambiar de tema las
empresas le apuestan al mes del orgullo
gay pese a las críticas y Ya estuvimos
aquí comentando un caso reciente con la
compañía Target un caso que vamos a
traer otra aquí a colación el gigante
minorista Target y la marca de cerveza
Bad light Fueron criticados por sus
esfuerzos para atraer a la comunidad
lgbtiq más y recibieron todavía más
críticas cuando intentaron dar marcha
atrás por eso decidieron seguir
respaldando y financiando los eventos
del orgullo en junio a pesar de que esta
celebración se ha convertido en un campo
minado para muchas compañías en medio de
la controversia que Se generó cuando
Target decidió eliminar muchos de sus
productos dirigidos a esta comunidad
muchas otras grandes empresas salieron a
defender sus patrocinios estamos
hablando de pepsico de Starbucks de
General Motors y de la matriz de Jeep
este el antes todas ellas grandes
financiadoras durante décadas de estos
eventos Y es que es probable que el
poder adquisitivo de la comunidad
lgbtiq más sea demasiado grande para que
las empresas lo ignoren lgbt capital que
es una compañía de inversión con sede en
Reino Unido
de Estados Unidos tiene más de 17
personas 17 millones de personas
pertenecientes a esta comunidad con más
de un billón de dólares en poder
adquisitivo millones de millones Pues
bueno por un lado por el otro la
visibilidad vamos a hablar de Hollywood
los actores votaron a favor de irse a la
huelga si fracasan las negociaciones y
se puede complicar potencialmente la
cosa en Hollywood se está viendo cómo se
complica el lunes cerró la votación del
Zac after que es el sindicato de actores
que reveló que el 97,91% de los
sufragios emitidos apoyaba una
autorización de huelga si es que no se
llega a un acuerdo con los estudios para
mejorar las condiciones el gremio reveló
que casi 65.000 personas o alrededor del
48% de sus miembros votaron por la
medida es que el sindicato Busca
aumentar la presión sobre los
principales estudios de cine y
televisión que ya están lidiando con un
paro laboral de guionistas su queja
principal es que necesitan más salarios
y también garantías contra el uso no
autorizado de sus imágenes a través de
la Inteligencia artificial
hemos entrado de lleno en la industria
del entretenimiento digital y de
transmisión y eso exige un contrato que
sea relevante para el nuevo modelo de
negocios entre tanto Daniela que ha
pasado con la huelga de los guionistas
bueno podríamos decir que nada el dos de
junio entraron en su segundo mes de
huelga no hay nuevas negociaciones
programadas con el gremio que representa
a 11.500 escritores de cine y televisión
y su salida interrumpió la producción de
programas nocturnos y cerró proyectos de
alto perfil incluida una nueva temporada
de stranger things de Netflix también un
spin-off de Game of thrones para hbo si
se le suma esta huelga ahora de actores
el cierre Sería mucho más amplio pues
Daniela no nos queda más que esperar Le
agradezco mucho y le deseo que tenga un
feliz resto de jornada Igualmente Ángela
nos vemos hasta mañana Claro que sí